[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
mitarbeiter
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert leben für den sport
sponsor von mir die lage in afghanistan
bestimmt auch heute den nachrichten tag
dramatische rettungsaktion
hunderte ausländer und afghanen werden
ausgeflogen auch die bundeswehr
beschleunigt ihre evakuierungs mission
wie umgehen mit den taliban nach der
machtübernahme sucht der westen nach
einer neuen strategie
erst das beben jetzt ein tropensturm in
haiti leiden menschen die alles verloren
haben unter schweren regenfällen
die bilder der verzweiflung aus kabul
seien beschämend sagt bundespräsident
steinmeier und gibt deutschland eine
mitverantwortung dafür die opposition
und viele andere werfen der
bundesregierung versagen vor
mittlerweile läuft die größte und sicher
eine der gefährlichsten
evakuierungsaktionen der bundeswehr in
der nacht soll in frankfurt am main die
erste maschine mit menschen landen die
so aus afghanistan heraus geholt werden
konnten aus berlin ist runs die menschen
wollen raus aus afghanistan
das demonstriert dieses bild als die
amerikaner am sonntag 640 menschen in
einem einzigen flugzeug aus fliegen eine
erste deutsche maschine hatte gestern
gerade mal sieben personen mitgenommen
inzwischen läuft auch die luftbrücke der
deutschen rettungsflieger vom
usbekischen taschkent aus wir planen und
führen durch mit zwei a400m jeweils drei
flüge zwischen usbekistan taschkent und
kabul um im rahmen einer luftbrücke
deutsche staatsangehörige aber auch
internationale angehörige ortskräfte
alles was sozusagen am flughafen abflug
bereit ist genaues zu fliegen insofern
setzen wir jetzt alles daran zusammen
mit den streitkräften der vereinigten
staaten dafür zu sorgen die situation am
flughafen so zu halten ist nicht nur der
flugbetrieb der ist mittlerweile
stabilisiert möglich sondern auch die
zugangssituation zum flughafen so ist
dass wir die menschen die über eine
berechtigung verfügen von ganz
ausgeflogen zu werden
dann auch zügig in die flugzeuge bringen
können geplant ist ein pendelverkehr
zwischen kabul und taschkent die
opposition kritisiert das in ihren augen
verspätete anlaufen der deutschen
rettungsaktionen möglicherweise ist die
folge dass gar nicht alle menschen die
es eigentlich verdient hätten evakuiert
werden können das ist eine erschütternde
aussicht für die die bundesregierung die
verantwortung trägt auch der
bundespräsident schaut auf die bilder
vom flughafen von kabul und auf den
afghanistan-einsatz generell
wir erleben in diesen tagen eine
menschliche tragödie für die wir
mitverantwortung tragen und eine
politische zäsur
die uns erschüttert und die welt
verändern wird derweil befürchtet nicht
nur die kanzlerin eine neue
flüchtlingsbewegung erst in einem
zweiten schritt will sie flüchtende in
europa aufnehmen bevor man über
kontingente spricht muss man erst mal
bin über sicherer
möglichkeiten für flüchtlinge in der
nachbarschaft von afghanistan reden ein
weiterer deutscher rettungsflieger mit
125 personen hat kabul nun verlassen
denn auch im auswärtigen ausschuss
morgen gibt es viele fragen zu klären
theo koll in berlin europa muss sich auf
neue flüchtlinge aus afghanistan
einstellen inwieweit wird deutschland
davon antworten übernehmen und wir
hatten heute zwar gleich von mehreren
bundesländern die bereitschafts
bekundung flüchtlinge aufzunehmen aber
zugleich hat berlins regierender
bürgermeister öffentlich bemängelt er
nehme mit erstaunen zur kenntnis dass es
keine bundesweite planung gebe der fokus
auf bundesebene ist aktuell sehr stark
geprägt von der vorstellung dass
flüchtlinge in den nachbarstaaten von
afghanistan unterkommen sollen und man
deshalb dort helfen und unterstützen
müsse das habe vorrang vor eigenen
aufnahme kontingenten es gibt zudem im
wahlkampf warnende stimmen es dürfe
jetzt kein zweites 2015 geben wie man
sagt als über eine million flüchtlinge
aus syrien nach deutschland kam das
könne ansonsten so vor allem die sorge
innerhalb der union der afg ein
willkommenes wahlkampfthema bescheren
also im moment klingt es danach dass man
angesichts von über einer halben million
afghanischer binnenflüchtlinge alles
versuchen wird möglichst viele taliban
fliegende in den nachbarstaaten
aufnehmen zu lassen die einschätzung von
theo koll aus berlin vielen dank
es ist schwer einzuschätzen was zur zeit
in kabul passiert die taliban geben sich
versöhnlich haben eine amnestie für alle
staatsbediensteten verkündet was das in
der praxis heißt wird sich in den
nächsten tagen und wochen zeigen luk
wallbott mit den bildern und
informationen die aus der stadt heraus
trinken
seit zwei tagen kontrollieren sie die
hauptstadt kabul trotz der angst vieler
bürger sind die taliban bemüht das
öffentliche leben wieder in gang zu
bringen lebensmittelpreise seien stark
gestiegen berichten bewohner es gibt
meldungen über plünderungen und
hausdurchsuchungen
die situation ist jetzt nicht normal
alle haben angst vieler verschanzen sich
so gut es geht in ihren häusern
im fernsehen zeigte sich an taliban
heute demonstrativ mit einer
interviewerin teil der botschaft wonach
die neue führung auch frauen gewisse
rechte einräumen möchte allerdings so
betonte nur kurze zeit später ein
führender taliban sprecher in einer
pressekonferenz in kabul alles im rahmen
der islamischen werte und der scharia
rechtssystems
die taliban seien nicht auf rache aus so
der sprecher der zugleich straffreiheit
für übersetzer und helfer ausländischer
organisationen ankündigt
doch die angst vieler menschen vor den
schwer bewaffneten kämpfern ist groß sie
kontrollieren inzwischen den zugang zum
flughafen eine schwer überwindbare hürde
für hilfskräfte wie osman der als
übersetzer für die bundespolizei
arbeitete
die taliban stehen jetzt etwa 100 meter
vor dem flughafen ich kann mit meiner
familie mit meinem kleinen kind da nicht
hin das ist für zu riskant
in der vergangenen nacht konnten wieder
erste militärmaschinen in kabul landen
und starten wie die evakuierung aller
ausländer und afghanischen helfer in den
kommenden tagen ablaufen soll ist noch
unklar
katrin eigendorf war für uns immer
wieder in afghanistan hält den kontakt
zu den menschen dort katrin wenn die
taliban jetzt versprechen die meinung
anderer zu respektieren und das frauen
nichts zu befürchten haben was ist davon
zu halten ich halte das für überhaupt
nicht glaubwürdig die taliban haben in
der vergangenheit schon des öfteren
solche versprechungen gemacht was sie
dann tatsächlich vor ort unternommen
haben spricht eine ganz andere sprache
man kann sich davon ein bild machen wenn
man sich die städte und gegenden und
provinzen an guckt in denen die taliban
die macht schon übernommen haben wir
sind dort in gesprächen mit menschen und
frauenrechtlerinnen die nachrichten die
von die wir von da bekommen sind ganz
andere frauen müssen sie sich wieder
verschleiern dürfen nicht alleine auf
die straße gehen scharia bedeutet eben
dass frauen unterdrückt werden dass sie
als menschen zweiter klasse gelten
mädchen dürfen nicht mehr in die schulen
gehen es hat sogar morde an kindern
gegeben weil mädchen nicht vernünftig
bekleidet waren nach meinung der
örtlichen taliban also das ist die
realität die eine ganz ganz anderes bild
vermittelt als das was die taliban
behaupten ich glaube in einem
afghanistan am islamischen emirat
afghanistan müssen die frauen fürchten
dass ihre rechte nicht mehr gewahrt sind
dankeschön katrin eigener
dass die us-geheimdienste nach so vielen
jahren in afghanistan von den taliban
überrumpelt wurden ist eine blamage auch
für den präsidenten es geht um das
ansehen amerikas als führungsmacht joe
biden rechtfertigte gestern abend seine
entscheidung die soldaten abzuziehen und
er richtete schwere vorwürfe an die
gestürzte afghanische führung mrt wissen
berichtet joe biden übernimmt zwar
verantwortung man habe nicht so schnell
mit der machtübernahme durch die taliban
gerechnet aber die schuld für das chaos
in kabul gibt er vor allem auf die
afghanische regierung und die ramme
amerikanische soldaten können und
sollten nicht in einem krieg kämpfen und
sterben in dem afghanische truppen
selbst nicht kämpfen wollen wir konnten
ihnen nicht den willen geben für ihre
zukunft zu kämpfen
jede neue terrorbedrohung werde man im
keim ersticken die bilder aus kabul so
beiden seien herzzerreißend aber die
afghanische regierung sei gegen eine
frühere evakuierung gewesen dann droht
er den taliban falls sie die weitere
rettung von menschen stören wollten wir
verteidigen unsere leute mit
vernichtender gewalt
wendecover stärke sieht anders aus
notieren die nachrichtensendungen wie
einst der abzug aus saigon das
beschämende ende des vietnamkrieges
bei der nato in brüssel heute fleht ein
afghanischer journalist in
die taliban bitte nicht anzuerkennen und
die frauen nicht wieder ihrem regime zu
überlassen
groß extrem eine extrem schwere
entscheidung die nato präsenz zu wenig
schwer auch deshalb weil ich ihren
schmerz teil
wir werden von den neuen machthabern
rechenschaft fordern die menschenrechte
einzuhalten vor allem die rechte der
frau
joe biden flug zurück in den urlaub nach
camp david das vakuum das die us
regierung hinterlässt könnten nun andere
füllen zb china und russland
fangen wir direkt nach bei unserem
korrespondenten in moskau axel sturm wie
steht russland zu den taliban welche
interessen verfolgt muss
ja für moskau dürfte vor allem der
schutz vor islamistischen terror jetzt
absolute priorität haben islamistische
terror der hat ja in den vergangenen
jahren immer wieder für große probleme
gesorgt
die überlegung ist folgendermaßen alles
was von afghanistan aus in nachbarländer
gelangen kann also zum beispiel nach
usbekistan oder nach tadschikistan kann
mittelfristig auch nach russland
gelangen das können flüchtlinge seien
natürlich aber auch waffen oder drogen
oder eben auch terroristen außerdem
betreibt russland in tadschikistan eine
große militärbasis und es gibt ein
verteidigungsbündnis zwischen russland
und anderen staaten zentralasiens die
sogenannte organisation für kollektive
sicherheit im rahmen derer moskau
sowieso im bündnisfall anderen
mitgliedern bei stehen müsste
live aus moskau
vielen dank
in hamburg gibt es eine große
afghanische exilgemeinde mit engen
verbindungen ins land die werden nun
genutzt um informationen aus kabul zu
bekommen und so weit möglich denen zu
helfen die in gefahr sind ralf
zimmermann von siewert berichtet über
ein projekt dass frauen in afghanistan
unterstützt
nadia nashiri mit ihrem mitarbeiter in
kabul seit jahrzehnten engagieren sie
und ihre mitstreiterinnen sich für
afghanistan mit dem fokus auf frauen und
kinder die lage heute etwas entspannter
die betonung auf etwas momentan von
unserer arbeit können wir sagen dass wir
erst drei projekte bei uns laufen und
wir haben jetzt bisher keine probleme
bisher gehabt aber für die frauen
natürlich die das haus verlassen die da
hingehen die wege das ist nicht
ungefährlich die schule in kundus mit
1000 schülerinnen und schülern etwa
läuft bislang reibungslos weiter der
afghanische frauen verein hat immer auf
strikte neutralität und nie auf den
vermeintlichen militärischen schutz der
nato staaten gesetzt erstaunlich gut
jedenfalls in diesem projekt
funktioniert zurzeit auch noch der
informationsaustausch also eigentlich
ist die kommunikation erstaunlich gut
wir telefonieren ab 6 uhr morgens mit
allen kollegen in den verschiedenen
projekten holen o-töne einholen fragen
wie die situation ist die kollegen
berichten was sie in der lage sind zu
tun eine sorge allerdings treibt da
diana hier auch um nämlich die
ankündigung der deutschen regierung die
entwicklungshilfe erstmal auf eis zu
legen es wäre ja wichtig dass man
afghanistan nicht im stich lässt an dass
afghanistan weiterhin unterstützt wird
und die menschen in afghanistan
sie mögen die deutschen in deutschland
ist einzuführen ein verlässlicher
partner und das darf das land darf auf
keinen fall auch so alleingelassen
werden für den frauen verein gibt es
zurzeit viele hoffnungen sicherheit
dagegen das ahnen sie hier auch die gibt
es wohl noch lange nicht
was sich in afghanistan tot und welchen
erfolg die rettungsbemühungen haben auf
heute de und in unsere zdf heute app
halten wir sie über alle aktuellen
entwicklungen in einem live blog auf dem
laufenden
nach haiti dort ist die not groß vor
drei tagen starben bei dem schweren
erdbeben mehr als 1400 menschen
zehntausende haben kein dach mehr über
dem kopf und jetzt dann der tropensturm
grace genau über dem krisengebiet
besonders stark betroffen ist der ort
liegt im süden von haiti überall dort
wasser und schlamm aufgrund der großen
regenmenge drohen weitere
überschwemmungen und erdrutsche claudia
bertz berichtet
die provisorischen zelte haben dem regen
und sturm nicht stand gehalten die
pfosten über die plastikplanen gespannt
waren ragen ins nichts nun gibt es gar
keinen schutz mehr für die dänen das
erdbeben alles genommen hat außer ihr
blankes leben sie kauern unter den
fetzen die übrigblieben am frühen morgen
versuchen sie die planen wieder zu
befestigen jeder packt mit an im matsch
des früheren fußball platzes
der regen ist auf uns niedergeprasselt
wir haben auf stühlen geschlafen hier
kommt niemand um uns zu helfen wir haben
kein dach über dem kopf aber ich will
nicht nach hause gehen ich bin in gottes
händen
die klinik hier in league hatte die
verletzten draußen behandelt jetzt im
regen und sturm drängen sie sich drin
schlafen im sitzen es fehlt hier an
allem ein arzt sagt uns am telefon was
er von der internationalen hilfe
erwartet
wir müssen betonen dass wir verstärken
müssen was schon da ist anstatt hier
immer mal kurzfristig zu helfen das hat
langfristig keine wirkung wir müssen
aber langfristig investieren das wäre
der richtige weg
der sturm ist weitergezogen hat aber
erstmal die anstrengungen zunichte
gemacht in den trümmern nach weiteren
opfern zu suchen
wenn sie den opfern des erdbebens helfen
wollen das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe hat ein spendenkonto
eingerichtet die iban lautet de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 das stichwort zdf
nothilfe haiti weitere informationen
finden sie unter spenden zdf.de oder im
text auf seite 8 190
kurz noch ein blick auf die korona lage
in deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet 3912 neuinfektionen das sind
1432 mehr als vor einer woche außerdem
kamen innerhalb eines tages 28
todesfälle im zug die sieben tage
inzidenz liegt jetzt bei
37,4
im juli starben bei der deutschen
fluggast rote allein in der region um
ahrweiler
133 menschen jetzt hat landrat jürgen
pföhler sein amt niedergelegt
krankheitsbedingt schreibt die cdu
fraktion in der mitteilung heißt es
außerdem wichtig sei ein unbelasteter
personeller neuanfang gegen müller wird
ermittelt unter anderem wegen
fahrlässiger tötung sei ein krisenstab
soll die menschen an der art zu spät vor
der flut gewarnt haben
in ostfriesland hat ein tornado schwere
verwüstungen angerichtet die windhose
war gestern abend über die gemeinde
großheide gezogen der wirbelsturm deckte
dächer ab und knickte bäume um 50 häuser
wurden beschädigt fünf davon sind nicht
mehr bewohnbar die feuerwehr bezeichnete
das ausmaß der zerstörungen als
katastrophal dass niemand verletzt wurde
grenze an ein wunder
und jetzt fußball norbert heute abend
supercup der bvb gegen die bayern ja es
geht um den ersten titel der neuen
saison und es ist das erste direkte
kräftemessen der beiden erz rivalen im
kampf um die meisterschaft dortmund mit
viel rückenwind nach dem furiosen sieg
gegen frankfurt letzten samstag
das ist es worauf der bvb heute abend
hofft die nächste gala vorstellung ihres
earl in hand mit den wiedererstarkten
kapitän marco es viele verletzte im team
trüben die aussichten etwas dennoch die
borussia macht sich bereit für den
ersten titel unter trainer rose es ist
ein prestige duell gegen gegen bayern
münchen und dementsprechend nehmen wir
das spiel natürlich
sehr ernst beim fc bayern wartet julian
nagelsmann auf seinen ersten sieg als
cheftrainer auch zum bundesliga
saisonauftakt gelang nur ein 1 1 gegen
gladbach vor anpfiff im westfalenstadion
vor 25.000 fans wird es eine
schweigeminute für gerd müller geben
der spanische fußball traditionsklub fc
barcelona hat erschreckende finanzzahlen
veröffentlicht die schulden des vereins
belaufen sich auf
1,35 milliarden euro einige
spitzenspieler sind deshalb offenbar zu
einem drastischen gehaltsverzicht bereit
deutschlands beste tennisspielerin
angelique kerber ist erfolgreich ins
wta-turnier in cincinnati gestartet sie
schlug die griechin maria sakari glatt
in zwei sätzen
die rund einmonatige pause nach ihrem
halbfinal-aus in wimbledon stand
angelique kerber gut getan zu haben
gegen die griechin maria sakar ii zeigt
sich die 33 jährige kielerin zwei
überlegene sätze lang um keine antwort
verlegen
dem insgesamt vierten match gegen die
griechische french-open-halbfinalisten
gewinnt kerber zum dritten mal doch noch
nie zuvor in einer solchen deutlichkeit
in kaum mehr als einer stunde
qualifiziert sich die seit jahren mit
abstand beste deutsche tennisspielerin
für die zweite runde in der sie morgen
auf die weltranglisten-fünfte elenas wie
turiner treffen wird
das was vom sport
das wetter bleibt eher kühl und nass die
details hat gleich katja hornuf im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn stellt sich
aus minister mars den fragen von
marietta slomka alles gute ihnen einen
schönen abend noch und bis morgen wenn
sie mögen
[Musik]
das sturmtief luciano ist heute von der
nordsee weiter zur ostsee gezogen und
seine kaltfront hat inzwischen bereits
ungarn erreicht weit im westen gibt es
ein neues hoch fridolin und das wird uns
dann ab morgen nachmittag im südwesten
mehr sonne bringen interessant sind aber
auch diese dichteren wolken die hier von
nordwesten heranziehen sie sehen dass
hier wiederholungslauf ganz schön die
bringen auch regen mit und er
beschäftigt uns auch in der nacht und
zwar ungefähr zwischen dem niederrhein
und dem alpenrand an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee sind einige schauer
unterwegs und im osten sinken die
temperaturen auf elf bis 9 grad im
norden und im westen bleibt es bei 14
bis 11 grad etwas milder und die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen morgen
recht einheitlich zwischen 16 grad im
fichtelgebirge und 22 grad rund um
leipzig und auch morgen vormittag geht's
noch regenfälle so zwischen dem
bergischen land und der donau die lassen
am nachmittag danach hier in
norddeutschland dagegen bleibt es wohl
den ganzen tag eher trüb da fällt immer
wieder regen am freundlichsten ist es
dann morgen nachmittag hier im südwesten
und in den nächsten tagen ändert sich
gerade beim wetter was die regenfälle
lassen mehr und mehr nach die sonnen
anteile leben zu und es wird auch ein
wärmer genannt